hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm Andrew Gordon got Andrew back on the
channel a day I saw this came out on
YouTube many hours ago I was gonna cover
it by myself but I was like if there's
any way I could get my buddy Andrew
Gordon to be here with me today you
covered the last two with me so I was
like the last of us to trailer we got
booze together Andrews he made time he's
here you excited I'm so pumped
it's my second favorite video game of
all time and if you're wondering what my
first favorite Zelda Ocarina of Time on
n64 oh good choice
yeah mine is the Superman game for n69 I
really felt like I became Superman in
the oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
mm they are not yo
and a graphics Wow join us all right you
all know the drill
are you rouse
Archy log books into anything you can't
hang a mask now ah
the liquors come back I hate those guys
oh no not her homegirl
Oh
talk
you have no idea what you're walking
into what are you doing you don't know
how large that group is how armed I
don't care
Oh Ellie
Joe asked me Joe what the hell are you
doing here Joe
we figured let you do this on your own
and those graphics are just incredible
where's the release date I literally
haven't gotten that spoiled for me yet
we're 21st close skin clothes oh damn
birds of prey Last of Us - Valentine's
Day my girlfriend's birthday so much
going on in February I gotta save up
some money man from what I've heard
about this game is that this is supposed
to be the longest game in Naughty Dog
history and everything we've learned so
far is literally just a tease of what
it's going to explore a thematically
plot point wise I'm just so excited to
see what epic tale they have in store I
feel like this could be a controversial
video game especially the day and age
now again where the subject is keeps
getting brought up of politicians saying
stuff like video games cause this I feel
like that like oh man I that's in that's
in the zeitgeist again it's always kind
of been there but now it's like more
prominent like with a game like The Last
of Us part two which is gonna deal a lot
with very adult themes and also taking
justice on the ones who wronged the
least that's what it's looking like here
with Ellie specific tale I feel like the
fans of the game are gonna love this and
I'm wonder if this would cause any
controversy either way doesn't matter to
me I'm gonna play the hell out of this
game I feel like everything is
controversial nowadays but yeah getting
back to like the story and it just it
looks very emojis obviously but just the
emotion like he felt just when Joel came
back on screen even tom is well but
hearing that those lines from joseon
think I was gonna let you do this by
yourself that relationship was like the
core point of the story of the first one
and why we got so invested on top of how
amazing the graphics and everything else
look Eliza's speaking of the graphics I
mean that straight-up just looks like
Troy Baker and Ashley Johnson I mean
when we see the bruises and the cuts it
just feels so real and yeah they said
just to really love what they're doing
and I think they said they've been
working on this game for like five years
now so I believe that every eight months
for the five years yeah you tell them
they really put their heart and soul
into this obviously you know spoilers if
you didn't play or watch you know on
YouTube bill the clips of the first game
obviously you know Joel you know told
the very big lie at the end of the first
game - Ellie it's gonna be interesting
seeing how that gets fleshed out and
what happens to their relationship as we
go through
the game I mean this just looks
incredible looks so entertaining and I
think you said something that I just
love I love other just teasing like
there's so much we don't know about yeah
I feel like they're setting up the basic
plot but I feel like it's gonna get
insanely complex yeah yeah the basic
plot of where she's gonna go pretty much
exactly the ones who were wronged it
seems like through girl from like I
couldn't tell that's her actual
girlfriend or just a girl who has the
potential to be your girlfriend if she
dies they the way they cut the trailer
at least makes it look like she was
killed in front of her and that's where
she's taking revenge
we're like one of the main reasons yeah
and we obviously know that Ellie's Indy
grows from the first game he played the
DLC you know that she had a relationship
with her friend there - yeah I mean I
think you're right I mean that's the way
they cut it leo I mean we'll definitely
find out what on February 21st or you
say it's long as game ever maybe on the
29th who knows how many that's gonna
take for us yeah no I mean it looks
really good I mean and again I just I
just love how real it feels like well
all this all the settings I like how
they're expanding on the sangs because
yeah we did go to a lot of locations in
the mers game you know you went to a lot
of different cities but I'm loving a lot
of these locations that they're picking
up and then we got but you see we got to
see the clickers back who knows though
which weather Gaines's are that we were
seeing in there too cuz we did see a lot
of the human characters that we maybe
were not familiar with and you mentioned
the masks that Ellie was wearing yeah
she was wearing a mask is obviously
she's a mutant you know in the first
game so she doesn't really need to wear
a mask is she hiding that from their
girlfriend huh gonna be interesting to
see what why she's wearing a mask you
know how they're in the last of those
part one there was a moment where you
could briefly play as Ellie I love
playing as only because she's the
prominent character here who you're
gonna be playing as do you think
there'll be a moment where you play as
Joel oh I'm sure I'm sure there'll be a
few moments where you play as Joel in
this game that has to be I mean I mean
you're gonna be Ellie for most of the
game which is honestly fine by me
because the scenes we get to play as
Ellie in the DLC and also and the snow
when you're you know fighting off the
cliff that that one guy I loved playing
as always so I have no problem making
her the promise but I gotta believe
you're gonna play at least a few scenes
with Jill I'm sure Joel's really old now
injured and it makes sense by degree
the big adventure wouldn't be with Joel
probably physical speaking was but I do
think that you know the story that is
left to tell some more of would be Ali's
journey I'm not a doctor or anything but
I was also thinking when Ellie had the
bone arrow on her things do you not want
to pull that out cuz you know you're
gonna start losing a lot more blood and
stuff and maybe I don't
as a doctor I would say that is not the
proper way to treat such a wound we
basically have my words out accurate
they are and they go yeah absolutely I
mean something tells me that Joel's
probably gonna die in the skin it just
seems likely or what if Ellie dies
survive and then three is Joel taking
remand man I mean either way regardless
of what happens I mean like I said this
game is gonna be very powerful and very
emotional I mean the first one was too
but I feel like this is gonna take it up
I know not just because they know people
are so freaking invested in a franchise
I mean yeah you could be right it could
be it could even be like how Terminator
dies the term IRA to where he just
slowly goes down a lot of he's accepted
his fate you know and you know ruining
the ending of the Last of Us is one
thing but ruining the ending of
terminators alright too soon right soon
I know my bad guys I apologize if you
have not seen terminator 2 my bad
spoiler ban has not been lifted yet man
all right guys thank you so much for
being here what are your hopes for the
Last of Us - what do you think will
happen in the video game sound off in
the comments below where your dialogue
belongs you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell Andrew Gordon does some stuff on
the internet follow him on social media
Twitter why not go there he's earned it
and also let's give a patron the day
shout out to a very special man named
Gregory Bullock Gregory me you're a
handsome guy
Gregory Bullock I wanted to say to you
dude I know that last time we talked it
was a while ago there were some
challenges and emotional obstacles even
having to go through which I totally
respect if you have to take some time to
get back to me see most people I give a
lot of crap for not getting back to me
but you I'm gonna give you as much time
as you need if you happen to see this
shout
just now I am lying why the hell haven't
you got him back to me yet man I know
you're going through some painful stuff
but whatever personal life things you
got going on I can't imagine that it
possibly outweighs the message I
recently sent you just wanted you to
know what's going on shout out complete